let's go to the White House and our
chief Washington correspondent that's
major Garrett major good morning to you
as you know the votes do not look good
in the Senate do you see any chances
that the president will sign this
measure without the money that he wants
for the wall well Gail he may have to
because the votes aren't there in the
Senate this process is going to have to
play off and what the president wanted
in between that process was a fight even
if it's just a symbolic fight and how
did that fight first get started
Wednesday night at the Capitol Hill club
a very familiar Republican watering hole
who was their budget director Mick
Mulvaney the incoming chief of staff he
started letting House Republicans know
Wednesday night the president had
changed his mind and would not sign a
funding bill that didn't include wall
funding that's when House Republicans
started to basically wonder what the
future strategy was they rushed over
here put a bill on the floor and for a
symbolic victory gave it to the
president yes the House voted your way
mr. president but the Senate and the
Senate Democrats remain an impediment
there may have to be a veto and override
a whole long process in the end the
president may have this symbolic fight
but not the money what are they going to
say to the workers now who will be it
without a job possibly but he possibly
say to all these people one thing to
look at Gail is we have a weekend coming
up some federal workers work but not
many the president's declared Christmas
Eve at federal holiday Christmas is a
holiday this make go until after
Christmas but the actual disruption
because of that unique scenario may be
less than it would be in previous
partial government shutdowns or full
government shutdowns but that's cold
comfort to those who are living with
this uncertainty a lot of uncertainty a
lot of senators flying now in this bad
weather I'm coming back to vote major
thank you